bienvenue dans la famille malaucène et
papa ne reste jamais longtemps
al'inverse des emmerdes qui ont ici
leurs habitudes tu es un port j'ai mis
du temps à faire les autobus parler
comme un charretier tué sauf que j'avais
des marchés petits crédits soient tous
tes enfants mes frangins les frangines
quoi pratiquer de saturne sur le statut
d'un radical benjamin c'est thérèse elle
cause les toiles qui trop superstitieux
lever et moi du toit juste équilibré ce
grand jeu familial et d'un coup
d'artifice d'explosion lundi oui un feu
d'artifice
quoi
est-ce que la zone nous chaque fois
qu'il fait des calculs rénaux il ya une
naissance dans la famille c'est quoi le
taekwondo c'est quand tout ce que tu
chips est multiplié par deux c'est pour
ça que ça s'appelle les quelques